I was on a flight from Louisiana to
Atlanta then heading back to LA and I
was on The Descent and I was very chilly
so I said better cover up and I pulled
out the blanket out of this sealed
plastic bag open it a little brown
crumble falls on me I was like Oh Me Oh
My what has that babe
but I forged your head because I'm
chilly so I like open it more and I see
this like brown thing in it so I drop it
because I was like is it an animal what
is it so then I open it with my foot
this man staring at me I'm in first
class thank you and
the smell hits me and I was like oh my
God oh my God I think that's a piece of
poop and then we landed and I went up to
the flight attendant I was like do you
hand sanitizer I think there's a piece
of poop in my blanket he was like girl
no and I said yes girl yes go look so he
goes he looks he goes oh my God
own